claude blanchemaison experts un relais
sur international bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être vous est-ce
que l'on peut parler de grandes
décisions aujourd'hui que peut-on
retenir
ah oui je crois que c'est une grande
innovation d'abord parce que tout le
monde reprocher l'union européenne
d'être immobile de regarder passer les
trains
et là tout d'un coup le l'union
européenne si la proposition
franco-allemande est acceptée va
accroître sa force de frappe de 500
milliards d'euros pour les années 2000
21 et 2022
et puis le budget de l'union européenne
est plafonnée à environ 1% du pnb les
états membres et l'allemagne tenait
beaucoup à cette limite et ne voulait
pas que cette limite soit dépassé alors
comment est on arrivé d'où sortent ces
500 milliards de d'euros
eh bien l'astuce consiste tout
simplement à autoriser ce qu'on
interdise auparavant c'est à dire
autorisé la commission à emprunter sur
les marchés financiers les états en
pâtissent fortement du trésor les
entreprises empruntent avec les
obligations pour les grandes entreprises
et la commission qui a un budget de près
de 170 millions milliards d'euros par an
n'avaient pas droit d'emprunter
eh bien on vient de l'autoriser à 6
encore une fois la proposition
franco-allemande est suivie on vient de
d'imaginer qu'elle pourra emprunter et
évidemment il n'aura aucun mal à
emprunter sur les marchés financiers
donc je crois que c'est une importante
novation et que la chancelière a fait
preuve d'un grand sens politique ans en
allant contre une partie de son
entourage qui finalement ne souhaitait
pas aller dans ce sens
alors puisqu'il s'agit d'un emprunt il
faudra bien le rembourser eh bien
d'abord comment sera dépensé cet argent
il sera il sera ajouté au budget
communautaire et la commission utilisera
ce fonds de relance pour faire des
notations aux entreprises au secteur
aux régions qui ont été le plus affectés
par la crise pour le remboursement
eh bien ce sont les états membres qui se
substitueront bénéficiaires des prêts
pour rembourser avec un échéancier qui
reste à négocier avec aussi des
conditions et des pourcentages qui reste
encore une fois à négocier entre les
états membres
alors je crois que tout ça va se mettre
en place et par ailleurs comme l'a dit
le président français
en dehors de ce fonds de relance les
deux dirigeants se sont mis d'accord
pour faire ce qui peut être fait dans le
cadre des traités en matière de santé
les traités prévoient que la santé ce
sont les états mais on peut sûrement
faire des stocks de précaution
on peut sûrement travailler et financer
la recherche sur les vaccins sur les
traitements
on peut faire en sorte que d'un agence
de santé surveille l'état de santé
l'état sanitaire les divers états
membres et ceci a été accepté
ainsi d'ailleurs que la recherche d'une
politique de souveraineté industrielle
avec un système de surveillance des
investissements étrangers
ceux ci avaient déjà commencé par dans
le peu d'enjeu dans un passé récent mais
ceci va être développé c'est donc une
décision franco-allemande qui est très
importante maintenant évidemment reste à
transposer au niveau des 27
justement quand blanche maison c'est la
question que l'on se pose comment cette
proposition les veines et le micro et
d'un gala merkel va pouvoir se
concrétiser
comme vous savez je suis plutôt
optimiste donc je pense que on va
pouvoir y arriver parce que d'abord au
cours des semaines précédentes beaucoup
de contacts ont été pris bien sûr avec
la commission avec la fonera yen qui est
très associée à ces travaux le aussi
avec un certain nombre d'états membres
et que d'ailleurs
l'idée de recourir à l'emprunt était une
idée qui avait fait son chemin au cours
des derniers mois les choses ont
beaucoup changé avec la crise du quorum
du coronavirus est je pense que les
états sont prêts maintenant aller dans
ce sens
bien sûr les italiens environ 500
millions c'est pas assez
il faudra que ce soit le double 500
milliards pardon il faudrait que ça soit
1000 milliards et puis probablement les
néerlandais vous regarder dans le détail
pour vérifier que ceux-ci ne revient pas
par un détour de raisonnement un petit
peu compliqué à mutualiser la tête
puisque ça c'est le point de rupture
qu'on fixe et les néerlandais
ils ne veulent pas de mutualisation de
la laine mais évidemment en fonction des
clés de remboursement que l'on définir
entre et amant il pourra y avoir une
partie en réalité de mutualisation de
des subventions qui auront été versées
aux entreprises au secteur ou aux
régions particulièrement touchées par la
crise alors et la commission doit faire
une proposition en bonne et due forme à
la fin du mois en principe le vin le je
crois que c'est le 27 mai est
effectivement ensuite les états membres
discuteront de cette proposition est sur
cette base sert ont trouvé un compromis
avec naturellement les bons offices du
président du conseil européen je relève
aussi qu'à partir du 1er juillet c'est
l'allemagne qui exerce la présidence des
conseils des ministres
donc le conseil des mythes et finance
est propre que l'allemagne aura à coeur
de mener ce projet à bien et on peut
penser que le parlement européen sera
aussi favorable puisqu'il souhaitait que
les moyens financiers de l'union
européenne soit accrue
certains états membres sans doute aussi
besoin d'une ratification par leurs
parlements club blanchemaison dernière
question quelles seront les implications
politiques de ces décisions en europe
ben je crois que les applications sont
importantes puisque en effet c'est un
petit peu ce soir
une résurrection de la capacité à faire
des propositions et effectivement ça
passe par le tandem franco allemand un
travail assez important a été fait au
cours des dernières semaines
et comme je le disais tout à l'heure nos
partenaires sont déjà au courant alors
il reste en effet pas mal de discussions
à conduire mais ce sera surtout sur la
base des propositions de la de la
commission je pense aussi qu'il est
important
finalement quelques quelques jours après
la décision de la cour constitutionnelle
de karlsruhe que la présidence allemande
que la présidente al que la nation se
dire un nombre s'engage dans cette voie
bien sûr elle ne peut pas contredire
ouvertement de front la cour
constitutionnelle qui est un organe très
important en allemagne mais elle montre
que elle est prête à s'engager
politiquement avec son gouvernement à
fond pour sauver l'europe et sauver la
zone euro
donc ça je crois que c'est très
important à un moment où dans quelques
diverses parties du monde mais aussi à
l'intérieur de l'europe
on pense que l'europe est en mauvaise
posture merci claude blanche maison pour
votre analyse complète de la situation
après donc ces annonces des manuels
macro et d'un gué la merkel et à
l'instant une réaction celle de
christine lagarde
la patronne du fmi les propositions
franco allemandes sont pour l ambitieux
ciblées et bienvenus